so how many bridges would you say you
dove and inspected over your career
oh my goodness go ahead mike
i can tell you that keep this thing a
little bit closer to you when you're
talking
i can tell you that a typical bridge
inspection crew and i'm talking about a
top side crew would get it
approximately depending on the size of
the structures um
you know discounting the large howard
franklin courtney campbell types but
normal
3 5 10 15 20 span bridges
a crew of two people might get 30 of
those a month
to expect of those perhaps
20 percent maybe would be a bridges over
water
and would require a dive team to to come
in and do their
part of the inspection and then the
topside
crew takes the dive report combines it
with their
inspection findings and produces a
standalone document that
reflects the underwater in the top side
so
30 a month times 12 months
times 30 years i don't have a calculator
but it's a lot
that's a lot yeah and i think
probably because i was strictly diving
and we covered actually two districts by
the time i left
thousands thousands and some of the
longer ones like the skyway
uh when when you talk about doing the
skyway the skyway
isn't the scariest bridge i could think
of um
good good that's what steve irwin said
too
steve irwin came out here and dove on
that one time and he really is the
scariest one yeah
[Music]
i don't understand why why is that scary
not some i mean
there's scarier bridges scary bridges
that we have even in pinellas county
probably one of the scariest ones for me
would be john's pass
because it's right there right i feel
like it's scarier because there's
so much water like there's so such a big
distance between
the each piece of land john's pass i
could i could hit a golf ball
over johnson absolutely which
concentrates all the bad things in one
spot doesn't it
oh interesting so what's so scary about
is john's past would you say that's the
scariest channel you've
dove well number one it's right on the
water like sebastian and some of the
other ones
it's almost impossible to dive uh
whenever you want you have to pick your
time cautiously and carefully because of
the currents because of the velocity
four four five
six feet a second that's pretty fast
back in the 70s and 80s there was a lot
of
commercial fishing going on and a lot of
the commercial boats came into
john's past that's the grouper capital
of the world on the west coast of
florida
and they would flay their fish and uh
discard the carcasses
near the pass because that's where most
of the commercial fish houses were
a lot of sharks there's a lot of traffic
in and out for following the boats
people fishing swimmers it was also 50
feet deep
people don't realize that it was 50 feet
deep
they recently replaced it due in large
fact that many of the piling had
completely washed out and become
unsupported and were dangling in the air
out dangling in the water
so it was you know replaced and they put
a fantastic new structure up there
velocity fish animals they've had
several drownings there
people getting sucked off the into past
and the current stuff
it's it's pretty dangerous boat traffic
is pretty narrow also
uh we didn't you know necessarily uh
back then have three people in the boat
like i said a lot of times we would tie
our boat up and just
both of us go in to make sure we were
okay in the water so there's a lot of
stuff that made different bridges hairy
there were some bridges down in
alligator alley
that you know you really had to think
twice and look twice before you went in
when they opened that up those
alligators had never seen divers before
i can guarantee you run into alligators
when you're diving those bridges
frequently really well that's how do you
get how do you uh what do you do when
you're underwater
like well i tried to call manny but i
couldn't get manny to come out
they needed one of those tridents over
there he's going to go ahead and go out
there and lift them up and
and play with him and stuff but uh manny
hey
how you doing you know i just i'm not
manny
um unfortunately we've had we've had a
couple of brush ups with with some
alligators and stuff that
didn't end up very well for the
alligator
because we're both still here but uh you
know we don't look for it it's just
one of those things if you're in florida
you can almost always count on
bumping into an alligator in the water
and especially now uh with the
popularity
generally they're they're not
territorial or aggressive
they're more likely to retreat than
attack as my experience
in my experience because i though with
the d.o.t a little bit longer than mike
was
if you get a construction crew that's
out there feeding them for three months
they're left over lunch yeah then they
usually are pretty interested in seeing
what you're going to bring in
for lunch when you get in the water so
it made it kind of interesting we had a
hard time a lot of time
we would stop down on the everglades at
places where the people would stop in
the bus and actually feed them
even though they weren't supposed to
back then well like i say it made it
more
difficult to do our job it's just part
of that thing that you signed up for
yeah it makes a lot of sense how now
that i think about it that
there is so like such a narrow channel
in john's past it makes sense that
there's
so much more sea life
coming and plus with the fishermen and
everything and and people and both
how deep is can you explain what it's
like
on a typical diet how many times did you
dive the skyway bridge
oh my goodness oh my gosh i i had
i'm going to say 22 years of diving off
the skyway bridge so i
that that's kind of the skyway like
every other
regular bridge in florida gets inspected
every two years
every two years some structures that are
weight restricted for whatever reason or
have structural deficiencies that the
inspectors want to monitor more closely
than two year cycle can be as frequently
as
twelve six even even three even one
month
they could go look at a structure every
month to make sure that it doesn't need
to be closed
so when you talk about how many times
that you dive the skyway
a typical inspection of the skyway for a
dive crew would probably take two months
really absolutely absolutely and that's
with like i say you don't get to pick
your weather or pick your visibility
sometimes you you go down
it may only be two or three feet and a
lot of it's
tactile it's not swimming across and
just looking at stuff
it's swimming across finding the
concrete piling
really almost shimmy up and down each
side and each face it's right in your
face it's more like a telephone
alignment
when you're climbing up and down the
piling and not only that but you have to
remove all the uh
barnacle growth to see what's underneath
so that that in itself is a
difficult task or enough so that you can
see what you're inspecting and stuff and
then if you find more you can go ahead
and bring in heavier equipment
there were times out in the early 70s
when we first saw the cracking on the
main piers
on the north side we spent hundreds of
hours out there with
pneumatic and with hydraulic equipment
cleaning the
large piers as big as this room
to find cracks as small as eighth of an
inch a quarter of an inch and then
documenting them
so that we could bring it back to the
engineer so that they could take a peek
at it
once they saw that we had some large
cracks large
up to a half an inch they would send us
back out on those cracks
with a homemade
jig with a hydraulic drill two inch core
and we would set it up on that concrete
structure and take core samples
at that crack location to see how far in
if we could
that crack went and see what kind of
material it was
there was about i'm guessing now about
12 or 14
piers on the north side and the south
side of both old skyways
and i think the we only found cracking
on the north side
of the newer of the two bridges that in
76
so a few of them are broken are cracked
but we do you know
you could spend 100 hours just on one
pier taking samples
we put pieces of glass on either side of
the crack
and epoxied up there and that way if the
pier did
shift or move that glass would more than
likely fracture or crack
if it got that bad that was our early
strain gauges
they hired consultant companies to
actually put strain gauges on
the opposite sides of the crack to see
if there was any movement stuff
there was a lot of testing going on
before the bridge was struck to see
if they were going to make significant
repairs to those piers
and other parts of the bridge as well
wow so you could spend
hundreds of hours just on an assigned
task
out of the skyway by the time that
bridge was struck in may 9th i figure i
had at least
a documented 200 miles
of underwater bridge inspection because
back then
there were we traveled the entire state
the seven
mile bridge is not a seven mile
inspection let's talk about the bridge
in the keys in the keys
it's nine miles because it's not just
swimming across and looking at
everything it
swim to that pier swim around it if you
can
go to the next beer swim around it if
you can
and keep going so that ends up to be
about nine miles because the skyway was
about
four four and a half miles by the time
you got done with that it was five
almost six miles because you didn't just
swim from
peer to peer you swam up and down you
swam the bench and stuff
so i know mike when he first
started uh i
i think it was a new experience for him
but for me i had been out there so i
based my
comments on five years of you know
full-time diving out there and stuff so
you know that was uh that was quite an
experience back in the
earlier days so the skyway wasn't scary
for you to die
i i think i was more comfortable just as
comfortable at the skyway
you had to be so comfortable diving yes
that you didn't think about it diving
was simply a mode of transportation to
get back and forth to our job
yeah you had to put everything else out
so that you could concentrate on your
inspections
yeah and typically we had pretty good
visit visibility out there
we were we were very fortunate west
coast of florida other than the keys
it you know has some excellent
visibility on and off jacksonville
not so much not so much not so much i
mean you know
we've got had good water there were
times out there when it was a lot of
feel and stuff but
on the day that the skyway went down
based on my time out there legacy
we had a good 30 foot of visibility
because mike was taking pictures of the
entire roadway
down there with this camera
you